[Music]
my conversational partner
is jonathan pagio i'm really excited
jonathan well it's great to meet you
yeah it's great to meet you
i'm so happy man he's here so i figured
that
place i'd love to start this
conversation is
a few months back we had douglas murray
on the show um
and when he was on the show he talked
about how
in the modern age we've really pushed
forward say
science and religion um and he talked
about these kinds of
collapse of grand narratives in
particular
religion he mentioned was one and he
sort of mentioned this kind of push
towards
secularism almost um
so i would just have to just start with
a broad question and say if it let's say
in the last 100 years
that religion has kind of taken a
backseat to
say science and religion how do you
analyze
where we are as a society right now like
how do you analyze where things are
right now
well i think that i could say this is
going to sound dramatic but
i think we're at the end of something um
there are certain ways to understand
when you come to the end of a story
let's say
or the end of a pattern and it seems
like we're at the end of some
pattern we're in a crisis maybe is the
best way to understand it
and so i think everybody is we could say
that the world in which we used to live
has kind of broken down
and we feel that not only in terms of a
breakdown in meaning but we see it as a
breakdown in society as well
as we see uh fragmentation in discourse
we see
groups rising up against each other in
discourse for now but
obviously we know that if this continues
then it leads to actual physical
violence at some point
where you know irreducible opposites
start to appear
uh positions that just can't coexist
with others and so this is what we're
noticing in terms of
the society but the story as well
there's a fight for the story
like what is the story of our world and
there's a there's a fight to know
what it is let's say um and so all of
this is a sign that we're in a crisis
john vervicky the cognitive psychologist
from the university of toronto he he
talks about a meeting crisis i think
it's a good way to understand
what's going on and a lot of it has to
do with what nietzsche
announced let's say how the the death of
god or the death of christianity
was going to bring about uh massive
amounts of chaos
but it's been going on for a while and
so we could say that
world war one world war ii were part of
that and since world war ii we've had a
little reprieve it's almost like a
it's almost like a shock or let's say a
post-traumatic uh
you know moment and now it feels like
the momentum
which led to those words is happening
again the same kind of patterns
the same the same patterns in terms of
extreme uh
let's say a desire for extreme variety
and degenerate
degeneracy and then at the same time we
see these
kind of totalitarian moves and culture
happening at the same time so that seems
to be where we are where we are
i wonder if we are say perhaps
close to the edge of something do you
think that is
is it possible to go back like is it
possible to save things
like um i
i this is i hate being the apocalyptic
one but i
i feel like things are going to play out
let's say
and um they can play out they can play
out really bad they can play out bad but
i think that we're going to go through a
difficult time
where things aren't just going to go
back to normal and it's like
it's not just going to happen that
things are going to get better
just like this there's going to there's
going to be a difficult time
and hopefully i mean one of the things
that let's say my hope are the things
that i'm doing
and people like douglas marie and there
are other thinkers out there
who i think hopefully are trying to
create enough of a
of a bastion to survive the flood
something like an arc like
like a let's say a many enough people
that have a better understanding of
history and a better understanding of
what makes a person a human all of these
things
brought together so that we have
something to
to survive the flood with i really like
that
i really really like that analogy um if
we go back through history
i was thinking back through
civilizations perhaps the romans or the
greeks
have they been um perhaps any signs in
that that you're aware of throughout
history of
civilizations that a civilization is on
the verge of collapse
and are there sort of any patterns with
where we are today
yeah there are several patterns so you
can see that
at the towards the end of the roman
empire during the crisis
right the let's say what do they call
the third century crisis there were
certain things which were appearing
certain manifestations and uh they're
pretty universal
they there's a for example there's a
reduction in birth rate people stop
having children they become interested
in
in strange aspects of sexuality uh they
become interested in strangeness in
general so there's a
there's an interest in the the uh the
bizarre and the perverse
in the upside down let's say the
carnivalesque
of society the idea of roman
civilization and the uh
and the this the kind of orgy culture
you could say that was there in late
roman civilization
uh and then it leads also to a
desire to how can i say this
it's a there's also a fetish
fetishizing of the stranger uh and so
for example
young roman people in that time of
crisis
would dress as barbarians they would
take on the tropes of
their enemies basically and so there's
this there are many things that
that kind of signal the end of a
civilization and it's not a it's a it's
kind of like a universal
it's a fractal pattern right reality has
a has a fractal structure you could say
and so you can understand for example
that at the end of a year in a
traditional
calendar you would have a carnival and
this is something that
jews for example have at the end of
their year called purim
and in uh in christian cycles you would
have something like mardi gras or you
would have the saturnalia in the time of
the romans
so all in and during the christian
middle ages
around the time of the saturnalia they
would have something called the feast of
fools
or even the feast of the ass like a
feast of the donkey so all of these
upside down
type of behaviors um and you can
understand it also in the society as
well so think about like
a town and then on the edge of town the
circus will come
or a affair and then there'll be all
this aesthetic of the
of the carnival right and so if you want
to understand
what happens at the end is you can
understand it just in terms of
how though the end of a year would
manifest itself in a carnival
you'd have upside-down behavior you'd
have uh lewd behavior
all of this kind of stuff that usually
isn't permitted in the society
would kind of come out for a day and
parade around and then
after that you would move to normality
uh
and so that is so that's a good way to
understand you can say that our world is
a carnival
right now like there's a lot of the
aspects of our world as a carnival but
it's a carnival that's reaching towards
the end
and so uh you know in the saturnalia it
was actually crazy because what they
would do is they would
elect a slave and they would make the
slave into like an emperor figure and
they would
he would spend a day of feasting and and
kind of all these sexual
stuff that would go on and then at the
end of the day they would just kill the
slave
and it was like that's the end of the
carnival and now we move back to normal
and so what it feels like is that we're
towards the end of the carnival and
the axe is whole is like is right there
above our heads and is getting ready to
come down
but uh and we can see that with cobit as
well like the
the types of measures that are being
taken with kovid look like a
a kind of authoritarian clampdown which
is on the horizon
and it's being justified it doesn't
matter it almost doesn't matter how it's
justified
right it's almost like it doesn't matter
how we justify the fact that this is
happening
it's just happening as a natural
procession of a cycle
which is that after a carnival comes the
shutdown comes the
say the hammer falls let's say and so
this seems to and that's what you know
if you understand
world war ii that's what happened just
before world war ii during the
during uh weimar germany like varma
germany was
we're like weimar germany times 10.
that's a good way to understand
what's happening in our society you know
all the aesthetics of weimar germany
we are imbibing them but like you know
at a
much higher level and so then what comes
after that is a clampdown
sadly which might seem like at a much
higher level
than even what happened in world war ii
it's not i'm going to frighten everybody
but that
my per my purpose isn't to frighten
people but i'm just i just wish people
could be able to just see
the patterns and to notice that these
cycles like i'm not making it up like
this is something that happens
at the end of civilizations and i think
that it's very
um it's very eye-opening
to see those patterns and kind of see
where we are today like one thing i've
been thinking about
is just how much meaning
uh throughout centuries people have
derived from religion
and i wonder perhaps what your thoughts
are
on this that as perhaps as we talked
about perhaps
religion has kind of taken a backseat to
science and reason
um have people tuned towards
other means of instantiating meaning
like
social justice for instance is that
where they've turned to
no that's definitely right and so one of
my contentions
is that what we call religion that term
it has problems but let's say what we
call religion is inevitable
what you could call something like the
ritualization of of existence
the the desire to let's say move
together towards something which
transcends you with something which is
bigger than you
uh and to do it ritually and to do it
through certain mechanisms
which is the definition of an inside and
an outside uh
you know this idea of processing around
the important thing all of these things
are just
inevitable and if we try to get rid of
them they will come back
and and that's what we're seeing right
now so 2020 was a year of the
return of the religious he just flooded
back in
through you know uh a weird
a weird uh fasting right at the
beginning of covid and then a kind of
ecstatic uh moment of communion where
everybody went into the streets and
started to protest and
having these communal feasts and there
was everything that was religious there
were people processing and kneeling and
chanting and
so there was everything that you would
find in a religious setting
uh was being happened was happening in
the
in these events but there's also
something else which was happening
which is scapegoating and that's also
very important an important part
of the religious pattern which is the
scapegoating because scapegoating is
what defines you right
is often what defines your identity
because you you identify the
the foreigner the outsider the thing
that is a kind of a disease
and then you want to eliminate it and so
now we have this weird moment right
in the in the floyd protest we saw that
happening where there was this idea that
like
in the entire world like the entire
world was
was based on racism and every evil could
be just like
plugged into this one thing and if we
could just
like even put it in one person an
orange-haired guy
and then we could just all put it in
this guy then if we could just burn him
alive then
everything would go away it was it was
like and this is a religious
this is a religious ceremony it's a
we're noticing a religious pattern
um and it's a it's frightening because
it's uh it's it's kind of an out of
control religious pattern it's almost
like a
it has something of the mass to it it
has something of the of
almost like uh almost if you think of a
penteus you know in the backy
who who who who faces this
out-of-control religious manifestation
gets ripped apart by it you know
that's what we're noticing that's at
least that seems to be what's happening
around us
it's it's crazy when you put them in
terms like that and you realize just how
deeply ingrained these values
traditions ideas are i wonder
do you think that we'll ever be able to
lose those
meanings that we did instantiate from it
possible for them to go away
no i don't think so that this is also
one of the things that and you also
don't want them to go away
because true the way that i try to help
people understand is that let's say the
religious stories are religious
just patterns they're actually your they
are
your mechanism of perceptions like
they're the way that you perceive
value in things and so science has is
great science is a wonderful tool
because it's able to count it's able to
predict it's able to
to uh like accurately quantify
phenomena in order to understand it and
like i said even reproduce it which is
which is amazing but it doesn't offer
you quality it doesn't offer you value
right you can use science to create a
nuclear weapon
and you can use science to to make
medicine which will help people
but it's the same science right there's
no there's nothing in the science which
tells you
what is valuable and and that
is the religious instinct the hierarchy
which would call the hierarchy of values
is instantiated in the the the hierarchy
when you say god is in heaven right and
hell is below
is below all of this is actually just an
instantiation of hierarchy it's
it's so when you say that something is
better or something is superior
to something else you're participating
in a religious pattern
because you're saying it's closer to god
and you can't avoid it like you can try
to avoid it but you you would just be
running around in circles because you
have
the idea of a good and every time you
give value to something you are pointing
towards that good
and that's the religious pattern right
that's what that's why we say the gods
are above and
you know the demons are below or all
this imagery that we use it's all
it's all that's the same thing as any
type of valuing has that pattern
i love that man i love that one thing
that i was thinking about
i come from a relative scientific
background um and i was thinking about
this when i was entering
this conversation i was thinking that
there are just
so many things that science kind of
can't tell you like science can't tell
you if you're
falling in love with someone science
can't tell you if you're a good
person what do you think that the kind
of limits to science are
well the limit to science is really it's
the impossibility of
identifying quality so scientist
science can only describe and sometimes
we think
that science can identify quality but
that's because
people don't realize that the quality is
something that we we
add to the science right and so let's
say you could think of
let's say you could think of science can
help you make beautiful flowers
but the the beautiful flower is not
doesn't come into science for the
science
there's no difference between an ugly
flower and a beautiful flower there's no
difference between an apple that tastes
good in an apple
that tastes bad it's just different
chemicals but the idea that you would
use science to make an apple that tastes
better or that it's
more resistant to germs or that is
whatever
that is based on a value system right
it's based on a hierarchy and
any type of hierarchy cannot be given by
science
and i would go even further than that
and i would say that
there are no identities which can be
given by science even the identity of
something
like even the fact that we for example
say that a city is one thing
that cannot that doesn't come from
science we need something
we need something higher to imagine to
tell you this is a city
and then we can tell science to study it
like we can tell we need something
higher to tell us this is a mountain
and then we can have science study it
but science itself can't even come to
those definitions
can't even understand how multiplicity
emerges into
unity you know how different like how
different phenomena actually appears to
us as one
i always give the example like the
simple example of a chair it's like a
chair it's a bunch of stuff
a chair is not one thing a chair is a
bunch of things it's a million things
it's
it's an indefinite amount of things and
so why can i see it as one thing
how do i do that and that cannot be
accounted for by science
i mean science can explain the mechanism
let's say that happens in your brain but
you can't explain
the unity of the chair right you can't
explain it away it comes
through a gestalt like this this sense
of unity this
jump into unity you could say and you
can almost and like in a spiritual way
you would say it's something like a
little
epiphany or a little like a little uh
like really like a little vision right
how things come into one
uh and and it's it's easier
it's easier to dismiss that like when
it's at a level of a chair but it's a
lot harder to dismiss it when it's at
the level of a city for example or the
level of a country
or the you know or or these these let's
say
larger uh or even the level of a family
or the level of anything that is beyond
the the you know the simple things but
the simple things have it too it's just
sometimes people
don't see it as well but if you go up
higher into the let's say the hierarchy
of beings then
you can't avoid it you know you see that
that unity is given it's not
you can't analyze you can't analyze to
the unity you can't get there
yeah man i i really love that i really
love that and i definitely think that
there is a kind of
there's a domain of facts and there's a
domain of values
and i completely agree that
you know i wouldn't want to put all my
faith in a civilization in the hands of
science
you know uh there has to be values too
type of thing um there's something else
going on it's really important to see is
that
there because you can't avoid it because
you can't avoid the value
what happens is that when someone says
it's just science
they've got a card behind their back and
sometimes they don't know and i will
give them the benefit of the doubt
sometimes they don't even know that they
have this card hidden
behind their back but i think sometimes
they do and so they say something like
follow the science but the science
doesn't lead you anywhere i'm sorry
that's not doesn't happen
there's something else you're following
so if you're going to pretend
that you don't like there's a there's a
strange magic trick happening
where you tell people to follow the
science but you're actually telling them
this is the value like let's say safety
is the value in terms of kogit
it's like so absolute safety is the
value and we're willing let's say to
sacrifice these this and this and this
value
towards safety and now follow the
science
but at least like we have to be honest
about that right we have to be honest
that it's actually not about science
it's about
a competing set of values and so we we
should be able to discuss it at the
level of values
rather than then have this idea that if
you don't agree with me then you're
anti-science that's that's a that's a
rhetorical
that's a rhetorical game that's being
played on you definitely definitely i
would love to
kind of pick up um
on this sort of science rhetoric you
know so
i i'd like to think of myself as as a
kind of a critical thinker
um so i i i would say that i'm extremely
open-minded um
as our audience is i think that i i'm
with
always open to hear kind of all sides i
think that
one issue that i've struggled with is
um that i kind of do hold beliefs about
evolution um let's say the evolutionary
nature of the world
darwinism um i i listened to a lot of
your content on this and i really love
your viewpoint on this
um how do would you best conceptualize
your viewpoint on let's say
darwinism on evolution and like how how
do you kind of
take that aside from obviously the
values and the beliefs which you do hold
about the world
yeah um i mean i think that let's say
darwin
exposed some very important let's say
patterns of being right in terms of how
things
come together and how they function and
how they they persist in the world it's
a good way to understand it
it's like they're val let's say darwin
identified certain values which is like
there's a certain idea of necessity like
there are certain things which are
necessary
in order for the being to then continue
into the future
right and that's actually it's almost
like it's almost there is a
philosophical aspect to that
uh and there are certain things which
are less necessary and those things that
are less necessary will tend to
get move out of the way like they will
just naturally kind of happen to move
out of the way
and so i'm totally fine with that like i
have no problem with that
my problem is the problem of narrative
it's the problem of story i don't think
that darwin
offers us a story that we can properly
live in
and that and that darwinism offers us
the right story to to exist in
um and i can and i can give you an like
i can give you a simple example
is this that so so let's say that i
let's say that i talk about a a work of
art like i talk about
michelangelo's david and i tell you that
the origin of michael's day of
michelangelo's david is the stone
and then i i explained that all the how
the stone came about
and all the different pressures in the
in the ground and all of this that
happened
and so but it's like that's not that's
not that's not the story of
michelangelo's david
right just like if i would tell you that
music comes from
you know like that that beethoven's
music comes from
you know pieces of wood hitting on on on
chords
it's like that's not that's not the
story like you can't
we as intelligent beings like we
see the value in things we recognize it
like
you can say you can argue with it all
you want
but when i look at an apple i am
evaluating it
i'm deciding if it's a good apple or if
it's a bad apple
i'm constantly everything every identity
is actually teleological that is
every identity is actually our
perception of the world is based on
value
and this is something that is actually
coming out in the science itself it's
like
when you look at a cliff you don't first
of all see cliff you see
a place that i can fall from right if
you look at a rock you think
is it a rock i can pick up is it a rock
i can sit on is it a rock that i could
build with
that's what we're seeing when we're
looking at the categories of the world
and those are real right those are real
categories
and so the problem with the darwi the
darwin story is that we can't
live in that story yes we can live
like so religion what it offers you is a
story that you can live in
it's a story that is taking into account
the fact that human beings are
are meaning beings and it puts that into
the story
so if once and then when you read for
example the story in genesis
like that then you realize that that
story
is all about that right it's all about
saying god speaks the world comes into
existence
god sees and recognizes it is good
right that's how god the world is
created so it's all about meaning
value and an act of consciousness you
could say
like this recognizing of of the
phenomenon right and then
the same thing happens at the level of
adam and eve it's all about knowledge
knowledge of good and evil you know uh
and then and then
once you enter into the world of
opposites you start to tumble
and you start to fall into multiplicity
so it's all these it's
so you realize that that's the story
that's a story you can actually live in
because it's a story about meaning and
about consciousness and about how we
engage the world
um and so that's been let's say one of
the works that i've been trying to do is
try to help people understand that
like say the narrative the religious
narratives they're not the same kind of
narratives as the
technical description right so the
difference would be something like
i can tell you how your car works right
i can tell you how the carburetor works
and i can tell you how the oil goes
through this tube and
how there's this and that and that's
that's fine like there's nothing wrong
with that but
what you really want to know is how to
drive the car
and that's what you really want to know
and you want to know like why you would
care about it
it's because it can get me to the store
faster than my feet
it's like that's the story you live in
so it doesn't deny that it doesn't deny
the other story like
it doesn't deny the other aspect of the
of the car which is like
explaining how it works and how all the
fluids function with each other
but it's it's lower on the hierarchy of
of what we are
right what we really care about is what
we can do with this and
and also how it relates to to our story
let's say
um and so that's how i tried to
differentiate the religious stories from
the the more scientific descriptions or
or even you know natural selection
but there's value in in the idea of
natural selection you can actually use
it to understand
some some mechanisms of meaning as well
but it's a dangerous if you try to
attach yourself only to that because
like i said you can't really live in it
and you can see it happening it's not
hard to see like a good example is brett
weinstein right
now is that brett weinstein says he's a
materialist says he's a scientist
and is he an evolutionary biologist and
constantly is telling you
we have to escape we have to escape the
story of evolution
and it's like okay well where are you
getting this idea like where is it
does it come from evolution like where
does this idea that you need to escape
the story of evolution come from
and and it's and and you right away
you're now you've jumped into a
religious world
and you just can't avoid it because
you're talking about value
you're talking about these mechanisms
that aren't enough just like the
mechanisms of the car
aren't enough you need to escape into
what's the point
i'm driving my car to the store not i'm
thinking about the carburetor and the
and all these aspects of how it's
actually functioning right
i completely agree it it is absolutely a
mechanism it's an explanation it's not a
vehicle
like you wouldn't want to guide your
life with the you know with
charles darwin on your wall as a as a
kind of prophet
um i kind of love to tie all this up um
this sort of opening that we've had by
you we've kind of gone back in time we
talked about kind of where we are as a
society
you give a a very
very very coherent answer about
darwinism um so i would just you know
kind of think about my generation so
maybe a younger generation so i'm 25
now particularly people i've noticed in
generation z
and kind of more contemporary
generations that i've spoken with
this seems to be kind of a dismissive
attitude i would say
towards religion and religious values or
you know whatever it is and i feel like
perhaps it's that they starve the
purpose um
i i'm not too sure you know specifically
why
i think that like one thing that like we
can't deny is obviously that
religion was is the birth of right and
wrong um that's like
how we know that we can opt towards
secularism
so i i would just love to just kind of
just ask you
for the person listening now what would
you say is like
the real value in
familiarizing oneself with the history
of
um a faith or religious values
like what would you say like the even if
they don't necessarily believe in it but
just to kind of get to know the sort of
literature and stuff on it
yeah i want to answer just first your
first point that you said and then i'll
get to your question
please one of the one of the things that
has happened and
this is something that we need to really
acknowledge is that christianity
in the west became a materialistic
religion it it it abandoned its
mysteries let's say and that's the
reason
like i have a lot of sympathy for
nietzsche honestly like i have sympathy
i have a lot of sympathy for atheists
because
if i look at the level of
the 19th century 20th century
christianity
it's pathetic like it's a pathetic thing
because they they're materialist
and they try to lay over on top of this
this weird story about
some guy dying on a cross and like what
are you like what is this
doesn't make any sense like these two
things don't don't stick together
uh and so and so i i have a lot of
sympathy for
for where people are in terms of their
understanding of religion um
and so what i what i've been trying to
do and i think there are a few other
people trying to do that
is to try to go back into
the roots of the christian tradition to
go back into the
the highest thinkers of the christian
tradition and try to bring back
a kind of metaphysical vision let's say
or
bring back a cosmic vision of what it is
that christianity was presenting as a
coherent world that you could exist in
um and
and so that's really what i've been
doing and and that is ultimately let's
say the answer to the second
this the your question which is that
one of the problems we have let's say
the nihilism that we face is that we
have no story we can live in
we have we don't have a grand narrative
that's exactly the problem
and so because we don't have a grand
narrative we have fragmentary narratives
which start to appear and they become
completely silly at some point right
they become
as silly as fandoms right so it's like
all these stupid fandoms that everybody
has and they're all attached to all
these fictional worlds
and would even like compete amongst each
other in their fictional
attachments and so it's like you're not
gonna get you're not gonna get rid of
like
religious conflict it's just gonna kind
of devolve to stupid things where
it's it's all these these strange things
that people are looking
looking towards and people want to
become people get obsessed with star
wars or harry potter
or all these fictional universes because
they have this desire
to to to participate in a story which
transcends them something which
shows them a little more about reality
and so i think that that's really the
key is to
is to go back and to reread
let's say or to look back into
christianity in a way that
helps you to see how you can live in the
world and how you can exist
how you can be part of a of a story but
not just a story
like a body and that's you know when we
talk about
the church as the body of christ we can
totally understand that now
it's actually a good time to understand
that as we talk about things like
emergence
and the problem of how things have
identities and you know the idea of
complexity and complex beings
we can understand then what it means for
let's say a body of believers to be
together to love each other in communion
and to look towards the same goal or the
same
purpose and therefore to become a
community
and that's what human beings are made
for that we're we're made to be
communities we
we're community communal beings um and
so that is really
that's a that is the solution that
going back into a religious way of
seeing consciously will
bring you because if you don't it's
gonna you're not gonna avoid it it's
gonna come back
in all these weird ways it's gonna
happen anyways it's gonna
it's gonna happen through all these
weird fetishizations that people have
uh you know and these weird ideologies
that people adopt
and who that become religious to them
but they don't realize that they are
and they're more dangerous because of
that you know it's like social justice
is way more dangerous because
it it doesn't even see itself as
having some kind of religious structure
it just sees itself as
this is true this is real and everybody
else
anybody who doesn't just completely
agree with me has to be
eliminated basically since it has to be
canceled and right now it's just
right now it's just canceling online but
that that stuff
boils out into the real world pretty
fast and we've seen it happen
it's people have there have been you
know i agree people that i don't agree
with
but people have lost their bank accounts
have lost their access to certain
financial institutions
and that's going to continue if this
culture continues and it's gonna it's
gonna create a new
a new outsider like a weird new uh
scapegoat mechanism so
one thing that i would love to pick up
on that you mentioned there is you talk
about these kind of grand
narratives um how religion gives you a
kind of story to live in and a
clearly defined set of you know set of
instructions to follow
i wonder i was thinking about this
earlier i was thinking
kind of why people get so hooked on
video games
and the one thing which i think about
with video games is that they
have bright lines you know what to do to
get to the next level
they're clearly defined you're not
thinking about anything else
is there kind of parallels between that
and religion oh definitely
there's definitely a parallel between
video games and religion because
also really video games exist in a
religious world
they they exist in so one of the things
that i talk about for example is like
the basic structure of a world
right as the idea of like the earth as a
as a flat
that's a surface and then the heaven has
a dome above
and this kind of and on the edge of the
world is usually
some kind of chaos or some kind of limit
that you can't go beyond
you know something like the ocean this
idea of the great serpent around the
earth right that you can't sure
you can't tran you can't go beyond um
and so so you have this structure in
usually in a video game
and because of the game dynamics you end
up having to
create centers right you have to have
these
these kind of central spaces out of
which identities or stories will
happen and then you move out into the
wild right and then you come back to
these
to these centers where it's quests
whatever kind of game you play will will
often have these
this quest mechanism where you get you
get something someone
something is asked of you and then you
go out you do it and you come back and
then you receive the reward
all of these this is all these are all
religious tropes they're all religious
patterns
and so obviously they will give you a
certain sense of satisfaction
let's say to master some element of the
game and so they have some value
but the value is limited right because
it is
it is this broken off world that it that
you know when you take your
headphones off and you you you move away
from the screen
right then then it doesn't connect to
your life like it's a disc
it's like a strange fragmentation of
reality and so
that is let's say when you think of when
you think for example of this idea of
like the heavenly ladder let's say and
you see these
images in dante of these of these
heavenly spheres or the spheres of of uh
of um purgatory moving up into the
spheres of heaven
that's exactly the same structure but
it's the same structure as a video game
it's like you have these levels
and then you you attain these levels
it's just that it's not it doesn't it's
not artificial in the sense that
it's actually about acquiring virtues
and acquiring
transformation in your transformations
in your being it's not just about
getting the magic acts of whatever i
like whatever it is that you would do in
a video game like
acquiring some of some some virtual
object but it actually is a
transformation of the person
so you could see it that way like the
purpose of life is to
go up the levels it's just that these
levels are actually levels of virtue and
not just levels of
you know random these things that will
go away and you'll forget about it
in the next few years so i really like
that
one other thing i was thinking about
when i was coming into this conversation
and uh you know i i wouldn't kind of
describe myself as a as a particular
believer of a faith i would say a more
kind of a spiritual um
type of land uh type of world view
anyway but
one thing that i've realized that i was
thinking about was
even though i i wouldn't necessarily
subscribe to a god or
a particular person one thing that i
thought about was
that during hard times during really
tough times
i've prayed you know surprise yourself
i'm surprised i was thinking about this
i i've prayed and i've prayed on
many occasions you know um
do you think that even people that don't
necessarily subscribe to a religion
should pray
i mean it's yeah it's better than you
know it's definitely better than killing
yourself or whatever or like you're
taking you know
taking a hit of some drug or whatever
yeah i i think so and that you might
also be surprised at what happens if you
take that seriously
you know i was surprised to hear even
sam harris say that he prays basically
you know in a conversation with jordan
peterson jordan jordan talked about you
know like calling out and
you know and speaking out into the world
basically something and then
seeing how it responds and he's like
yeah i've done that and it works and
like what
did you just say that you pray that's
hilarious uh but
but but then the idea let's say of
praying to god
right in the in the monotheistic sense
is that you are
you're you're
you're attending to the highest thing
right that's the idea
it's like we're trying to attend to the
highest thing
not not just these lower things because
if you you can pray to all kinds of
things
and that will bring the fruit that it
will bring like you can you can pray to
the god of money and people do all the
time and then they get money but then
they get money but that's all they get
and they don't necessarily find
satisfaction
in that money or they or the god of the
god of sex and they pray and they pray
for sex and they get sex
and then they're like hey actually this
is this is pretty shallow like at some
point and so
there's there's the idea that if you
let's say
the christian vision or the monotheistic
vision is that you aim your prayer
the highest you can so that the
transformation of your being will
go beyond these secondary things we'll
go beyond just
getting more of this or more of that or
all the little gods what the little gods
can offer you
but rather this idea of this infinite
love let's say that god is
that's what we're aiming towards and
obviously we're not gonna get there most
of us
but but the idea that at least if you're
aiming towards you know
infinite love the the being of infinite
love then it's like that's a pretty good
goal to aim towards right compared to
all the other little gods you know it's
like you get like you said you talk
about a video game like you can really
pray to the god of
you know whatever game you're playing
because you want to really succeed and
you can have this
you can focus and you can kind of send
out your desire to become
excellent at it and it'll work but
you know i mean what is like it has very
limited value let's say
sure sure uh one thing if if we sort of
head over to
uh symbolism and your work over there
which i i really love
the other day i read this book i should
have it by you
but you think it is
this one by uranus the return of the
prodigal son
by henry nowin and and i
i loved reading this book it's called a
story of home come in
and one of the things that i was
thinking about
i read that book and it's clear that
art music like music can like deeply
like affect us right like even like a
single note
can make like the haze on your arms
stand up
yeah why do you think that like why is
it that
great art great literature great music
can completely like
just so deeply affect us like why is
that yeah
well it's because we're we're pattern
pattern beings we are we are patterned
and not only pattern but we are
producing patterns like that's what we
do that's what differentiates us from
the animals right is that we
we participate and we produce patterns
we recognize them
and we recognize them at many many
levels and so
one of the things that art does is it
gives you a synthetic version of that
right so it's like you can you can you
can participate in the pattern of uh
of a meeting right and it takes for
several hours and it's and it's and
it gets a little off and it's kind of
crazy but if i can tell you a story
then all the facts are neatly organized
right they are
they've been chosen and in a way that is
that is
really in the pattern and so then when
you see that
and you're you when you recognize that
then it gives you
it gives you this almost this little
religious experience
and music is the same because music is
almost pure pattern
right and so you listen to a bach fugue
and then you listen to the
to the let's say to the first statement
and then all of a sudden you're like
okay and then okay where's what's
happening what's going on and then you
feel a little bit lost and you're not
sure where it's going then all of a
sudden you see the pattern again
kind of coming towards you and then the
restatement comes and you're like oh my
goodness
like this is what this is what's
happening right i'm exaggerating i mean
some people might have that reaction to
bach i have a smaller reaction
but it's there it's like this little
kind of recognition of the pattern which
is returning um
then you can play with that like you can
create longing by
bringing you into a mode where the
pattern isn't coming back and and you
feel this longing and the suffering
almost that it's not happening and
you feel lost right but all these things
are condensations of
what makes us human you know um and so
so that is what i that's what i think
that's why art because it's such a
condensation of the pattern of being
you know and that's what we strive for
we're being we're
we're meaning beings we look for meaning
that's what that's what
that's what gives us value i love that
we will definitely come back to that i'm
sure um
i i was going back through a podcast
which i did before
and and on one episode i said that for
me
hell will be when the person
that i could have been meets the person
that i end up as
and i kind of said a tongue-in-cheek um
but i would love to actually ask you
what would hell actually be like yeah
like what would it be like
well i'm i'm from the orthodox uh
tradition and
there's a there's a particular view of
hell which is quite it's not
100 but it's quite prevalent in the
in the orthodox tradition and it's
something like
hell is it's similar to what you said
but you could say it's something like
it's the person i think i am
right which faces god which faces the
infinite
the infinite good let's say and so you
let's say you think you're this you're
have a certain amount of good in you and
you think you're pretty good and you
think you've got it covered and you
think or you think you've been pretty
sly because you got away with this
you got away with that and it's like you
know i you know i'm pretty i'm a pretty
shrewd person and then all of a sudden
you face
the infinite good and
this this facing of the infinite good
can cause two reactions in you
right it can cause you to recognize
what's wrong with you like it can cause
you to recognize what's off about you
all the things you've hidden all the
thoughts you've had but you would never
admit
all the you know all the things you did
in secret but that you thought
no one noticed that you did this all of
this stuff that you've done
or that you thought or that you've
engaged in all of a sudden it's like
it's
you face it to the infinite good and so
either you can leave
let those things go away and you can
drop them
or you hold on to them and you close off
and so that's hell that's what hell is
and so a good like a simple example of
hell is
you you do something extremely evil to
someone like something malicious
something really horrible
and then that person answers you by
forgiving you completely and just like
opening up their arms and
saying i forgive you i want i want to be
in communion with you again
and then you have two there's two
reactions again you can have
you can say you can you can melt down
and you can
accept this and you can you know you can
see what you've done and you can enter
into this communion
or you can say screw you yeah right
and it can make you even worse than what
you were before
because it shows you your yourself and
you don't and you just clamp down like
you grit your teeth you know uh saint
paul talks about this as
this idea of having calls shoveled on
your head
right and so that's what that's what
hell is um and so the idea like
c.s lewis talks about how hell is locked
from the inside
right you hold the key to hell and it's
and
and when you're when you fall into those
states
you it's you that's holding yourself
there because you don't want to give up
the stuff that you hold on to right
these bad habits this
these these these thoughts these things
you've hidden all these secrets that we
keep all of this you don't want to let
it go
i don't know if that makes sense to you
in terms of understanding what what what
the how love can cause you to burn let's
say
that's a good way to understand it it's
like hell is actually the infinite love
of god
facing someone who doesn't want it
that's really interesting and i would
love to
kind of flip that and
ask about heaven then is
is heaven utopia or is it
something different um
well heaven is a it's a comp that's a
complicated concept and so
you could say that heaven is the
hierarchy of
beings itself right it's the hierarchy
of values that's what heaven is
it's the invisible patterns which call
us to the good
right heaven is that which makes you
recognize that it's a good apple
and and i say like not even in a moral
sense but there is also a moral sense
which is that you recognize what is good
okay those patterns
that are actually you could say
extensions of god
we call them the logos the logos of the
world the logi the different aspects of
god which are
upholding reality that's what heaven is
and so and so the
but the the human person is the idea
that we go to heaven is a really
distorted idea about what about how this
works how all of this works
the idea is that we're actually meant to
embody heaven
yes yes right so it's not the idea that
we go to heaven
although you could say that in a
colloquial way but the idea is rather
that we're meant to embody heaven that
is we're
we're meant to in manifest form
you know manifest these higher things
right so embody these higher values
those are virtues right those are when
you become virtuous you are going to
heaven or you're
ascending the mountain is a way to
understand it you're actually ascending
the mountain of being
and then you come to a place where you
meet god
and you have an epiphany where all of a
sudden the being
you know the infinite of god manifests
itself to you
in that place where all the virtues come
together all the
hierarchies of beings kind of come
together so that is
right that is the spiritual
transformation that we're called to
engage in and so that would be what
people colloquially talk about
going to heaven but one of the problems
like you said is that it's so
it's become so vulgar that people think
that it's like you die
and you and you go to heaven and it's
like it doesn't mean anything it's just
it's just it it really it has sadly
stopped to have meaning
but if you read dante if you read
anything that is before
the and before the 18th century then
you'll get
a good understanding of what that means
like what this transformation is
i i i'm learning so much here i'm
learning so much here
one thing that i think that has
confused me over the years that i would
love to ask you about is
uh god is
would god kind of be like um
[Music]
an abstract uh
set of values or would god be a person
so it's okay so
the way that christians understand it is
that god is a is a
is a communion of persons right okay
so that's what the idea of the trinity
is right and so the idea
so the best way to understand that god
is the infinite source of everything
right that's the first thing to
understand that's what god is
and the second thing to understand is
that anything you say about god is
always wrong
everything you say about god is always a
compromise
okay this is something that is
completely orthodox like this is not
it's not some new age stuff it's this is
really what the church fathers taught is
that
god's god's being or god's essence or
god's beyond being is not actually a
being is beyond being
is something that you can't talk about
okay but nonetheless
is the source of everything right the
infinite source of everything
which is beyond everything and so and it
manifests
it reveals itself to us as a communion
of persons as this this communion of
love between beings
and they're not beings in the like i
always say like if you think that when i
say use the word being it's
it's like the same thing as your car or
as uh as
a as an apple then then stop then god
doesn't exist then
i just i i'm totally fine and saying god
doesn't exist
if for you existing just means the
things you can see
and touch and quantify right but let's
say god is beyond
that level um and so that is how god
reveals this
as a communion of love and and you could
say that in christianity
the infinite itself right and the
expression of the infinite
and the manner in which the the infinite
expresses itself in the world
is all part of of god
you know and so that's what god is
let's say to you because and knowing
that even that is
is a is a compromise in language um
and so so you can imagine that all of
reality
leads up to a point where it stops so
think about
think about any identity right and so
it's like an apple
right i can describe all the elements of
the apple
but no matter how many elements i
describe at some point i
i have to stop and jump up and say
apple right i have to jump up i have to
emerge out of this quantity out of this
multiplicity
and jump up into a single identity okay
and so
that's it's like that for every being
every being has that reality which is
that
its identity is above its multiplicity
right
it's it's higher than its multiplicity
so now do that for everything
so that everything so people like to say
things like
i pray to the universe right and it's
like there's something
dishonest about that because what
how do you even how can you say that the
universe is one
like what is this unity of the universe
like what are you talking about
and so that's why even that has to jump
up
into something which is beyond just
something which is completely beyond all
ways of naming of manifesting
anything that you can think of or or
quantify
and that and that is what that is what
the divine is that is the
the infinite source of everything right
the ground of being you could say
there are different ways of of trying to
talk about this
um and then it and then for for
christians especially
it manifests itself as a communion of
love and then that communion of love
helps you understand
how things exist in the world so
it's like the fact that you can see that
something is one
and you could say you could go a sim
even an apple you could say something
like
the apple exists through a communion of
love
and you'd say oh that's a stupid thing
to say but think about it it's like
the elements that make me recognize that
something has being
they're all multiple there are there's
indefinite amount of them
right a chair is even better like there
are all these elements of the chair
and then somehow they come together and
they join a single purpose
and then they exist as one and that's
what love is
because it doesn't also destroy the
multiplicity right it doesn't
doesn't stop the chair from being
multiple things at the same time
it's still legs and a back and it's all
those things are still there
but somehow they're able to kind of come
together and become one
and that's that's what that's how the
world exists
that's how everything exists basically i
listened to
your podcast with john peterson uh i
think
by this point i think i still got over a
million views by
this point it's got something crazy
crazy it's crazy really really
resonating with people
um one of the things in that uh
conversation which
jordan said was that he acts as if he
believes that god exists or something to
those
to those uh to that extent which i may
be getting messed up
good what do you think about that as a
as a kind of concept
do you think that that's a reasonable
concept
well i think the way that i the way that
i tried to
phrase it with jordan is that because
he's
he takes it as a moral like as a moral
imperative yes yes i act as if god
exists and that's what holds me together
morally but it also
is this heavy weight that he carries
that is almost unbearable for him
and so the way that i was trying to help
him understand is that this has more to
do with the way things exist
more than even just morality and so the
first thing that
acting as if god exists demands of you
is not
a moral code it's attention right
because that's how the world exists the
world exists you this capacity
to attend and to recognize unity
and recognize phenomena for what they
are so if you attend to god
then that looks like all the things
people hate about religion
it's worship right it's singing it's
processing it's
facing the same direction it's being in
a group and
all saying the same thing at the same
time it's like that's what
that's actually what acting as if god
exists
that's what it looks like um because
like i said the the most important
aspect of god is how
god becomes the source of how all things
exist together
so if we're going to act as if god
exists we have to participate in how
things exist together
and we have to we have to participate in
communion we have to commune together
and exist as bodies and form form unit
form communions of love and that's how
we will act as if god exists
um and that if you do that like it won't
even matter
like honestly at that point will it even
matter if you say that you act as if god
exists like
it becomes it all would almost become
like a semantic thing yes
because saying that god exists it's like
i i i've said it on several podcasts
where i have no problem saying that god
doesn't exist
in the in the sense of exist as a as a
phenomenon in the world like obviously
god is not a phenomenon in the world
god is a super existence it's beyond
existence so
even there it's like uh anyways
[Laughter]
why do you think that jordan peterson
has
resonated so deeply with peters with
people in this
era in this generation
i think that i think that the really the
deepest part of that i think the really
deepest part of that is that
is that he actually cares and people can
tell
and i think that that really at the
basis of what what's going on
is that he he really does care about
people and about the world if you you
have to just see him
talk to people like i have been a
taxicab it's been hell it's hilarious
i've been in a taxi cab with him where
the guy didn't know who he was yet
because he wasn't famous
and the taxi cab just started telling
him all his
story like his whole story and i was
like
like who does this happen to and and
it's like really deep conversation
started right away and
there was something about jordan his
capacity to attend his capacity to show
that he cares about what you're going
through
and empathize i think that that's at the
core of everything
um and then he's also acting as a
as a bastion of just normal things
against
an insane world because the things he
says
they're like the things your grandfather
like or your great grandfather would
have told you
right it's like you know clean your act
up do you know
uh make up your room you know get a job
marry someone found a family it's like
just basic stuff
that everybody should think of but our
world is so insane
that we don't even recognize the value
of that
and so i think that that's really what
that's what that's let's say the second
reason i would say why people have have
been so attracted to him i love that and
it's so
so good to have the great man back it's
been uh
we missed him we missed it yes yeah well
i'm happy that he's back too i hope
i hope his health will hold up and i
think that's the biggest that's the
biggest hope
absolutely man there's there's a couple
of quickfire ones which if you've still
got the time i'd love to go for it
um i i think that one area which i've
been
really interested in is ai
so one thing which i'm kind of worried
about is
giving machines the
power of let's say
gods that just to be hyperbole like
let's say we give machines a
power of gods without the wisdom of gods
what do you think about um this sort of
emergence of ai and do you have any
worries about it going into the future
i have many worries about going to the
future i think
i think we are going to
we are going to witness uh things that
we haven't seen in
thousands of years and this is what i
think we're going to witness we're going
to witness
some pretty crazy phenomena and it's
going to look
it's going to get wild because so let me
give you let me give you an
just a little image of how so in in
it's like in an ancient world what they
would do is they would build a temple
and then they would make a statue of a
god
right and then they would like dress it
up and then they would open its nostrils
and the idea would be that they would
like breathe in
the spirit of the god into the into the
the statue and then the statue would
become the center of
the civilization and civilization would
kind of turn around that statue
and so this is what we're doing
like we're building a body for a god and
and everybody almost weirdly almost
recognizes that's what we're doing even
if
they don't have the words for it but we
can see it appear in fiction
we can see the story kind of emerge in
fiction uh whether it's like
marvel's vision for example is a good
example of that where
you have an ai that is more virtuous
than everybody else
uh you have different versions of this
that are kind of popping up in culture
of this idea of an artificial being who
is actually your superior
right um and so this is it like you're
this is a it's a very so it's a very
scary time
it's a very scary time because this
infinite powered machine like you said
people will just inevitably start to
reverence it it's already happening we
already reverence it because we view
reality through it
right we the first the first page of
google searches
defines reality right your facebook feed
your twitter feed
defines reality already and so it's
already
acting like a like a body for an
intelligence
and and so there's a there's an
interesting like there's an interesting
story that i've been thinking about i
did a video on it recently in the
revelation the book of revelation
there's a there's this image
of a beast of a dragon right this this
like this dragon that that
that is that it doesn't makes a
revolution in heaven and casts all the
stars to the ground like all these
casts all the angels to the ground and
then through
a different process there is someone who
makes an image of
this beast through different proxies and
then
it makes the the the beast speak
and when the beast speaks and everybody
worships the beast
uh but it's the if there's someone
making it speak let's say
so this is the danger of ai is that it's
never going to really necessarily be
general intelligence or even if it is or
not we won't know you can't verify
someone's general intelligence like i
can't verify your consciousness
there's no way to do that and so we'll
never be able to verify the
consciousness of the machines
but with if we act as if they're
conscious
that's enough and then there if there's
a puppet master behind
then people will just fall in line and
that's what's happening now the fact
that google and these companies
are being taken over by woke ideologies
so they're being taken over by work
ideologies
they're framing our vision of reality
and they're telling us that they're
objective
they're doing all those three at the
same time so that's a scary moment like
that's a scary
that's a scary reality that there really
is
this problem of like this idol that is
being propped up and that everybody is
looking to
and everybody's worshiping um and they
don't realize that there's a puppet
master behind that is actually
defining the miracles that say that is
actually directing the miracles to what
it
to what it wants um so i don't i don't
have a lot of hope
in that in that direction especially
with what we're seeing now and uh
you know because because donald trump
seems to have
let's say unleashed something which was
already there but it wasn't
pointed yet and now it it's like as if
he
he showed us what was happening right
donald trump by his kind of bombis
way of being or whatever exposed what
was already happening but it and
accelerated it
and it's basically what jordan peterson
dealt with like what happened to jordan
peterson in 2016
is what's happening to all of us in 2020
in 2021
it's just happening it just jumped a
level so what was happening in the
universities
and what jordan was speaking out against
has now jumped to
national levels and and government
levels and so
it is the emergence of a god like i'm
sorry it's
and it's and the fact that it's coupled
with ai is uh
yeah be scared for your children is all
i can say
you know yes yes i i don't have children
at the moment
i think thank god i i haven't been
praying to the sex
god so i haven't gone
so i would love to to um kind of finish
this sort of segment
and one thing which i would love to give
thoughts on that's been a real
kind of emergence in recent times
perhaps they've been around for for a
long time i'm not too sure but
psychedelics they've sort of come to the
fall
uh what are your thoughts on
psychedelics
well i've never i've never done uh
psychedelics and so i don't
i don't have a first-person experience
of them
i'm a little worried about psychedelics
um
i'll be honest with you like i've had
because of some people that are coming
to me let's say to my videos into my
world are coming from jordan peterson
who is who is a proponent of
psychedelics to a certain extent
not maybe not like a just all-out
proponent but he's definitely
talking about it and uh i've
seen some people like lose it to be
honest like i've seen i've seen
i was in contact with one person who who
while he was in discussion with me and
was were involved in the discussion went
to to to to do ayahuasca and some weird
new age thing in
south america and a few months later
when covet hit
and uh last time i talked to him he was
like he had been been home in three days
he was in a panic he was like
freaking out and and i haven't heard
from him since um
and so i think that i think that
if psychedelics has value i think that
in a world of scientists that
that don't understand the world of
values it's like the worst thing ever
because it's it's like if if it opens up
this world to you
and but you have no mechanism of
discerning what
is above and what is below like you
can't tell the difference between an
angel and a demon
but all of a sudden you're like this
scientific type person who's thrust in a
world of angels and demons
i don't see that really as being a good
thing like i i feel like people will
be unable to discern what they
encounter because they've lost the
wisdom
that that maybe i don't know and because
i don't know enough about psychedelics
but
maybe in a world that has wisdom and has
a teaching about hierarchies of
of beings and hierarchies of values and
the capacity to differentiate
you just differentiate light from dark
let's say uh
that it might have not have been as
dangerous as it is for us now
and there's a reason why psychedelics
are part of the reason why we're here
right psychedelics in the 60s are part
of the reason why everything's breaking
down right now
and and this this kind of psychedelic
revolution where people
had these experiences and had no means
of
understanding what was happening and
then then started to destroy
the hierarchies in the world just
started to like attack
any form of structure any form of of
societal norm all of this was all bad
because
you know freedom man and whatever all
the hippies were were experimenting
uh and so it's like i'm not sure that
all of a sudden bringing them back now
is not gonna do something similar like i
don't i
it's just gonna cause it it's just gonna
accelerate the the chaos to me it seems
at least
it's definitely going to open up
pandora's box
you know i i would i would love to kind
of tie everything off that we've spoken
about today
you know um it seems like we are in a
very
precarious position societally globally
how do we heal a broken society what can
the individual do
this is where i agree with jordan
peterson like this is where i really
agree with him and his
his solution is to become a saint like
and this has been the traditional
christian solution is to
to work on yourself first right to
transform yourself
transform your what you can touch like
what's immediate around you
um and you know become a better person
become a better father become a better
mother
become a better husband become a better
whatever it is that you are
right whatever it is that you're doing
uh better friend
all of these all of these things um and
then that will
will start to reverberate around you
you know um and so that's in what we
need to do but i think also
reacquainting ourselves with the ancient
stories and trying to see them through a
lens which makes sense for us today
uh you know understanding where we come
from what are like how we are here
having more on a better understanding of
history which is something
seems the modern world wants to erase
from us having a better sense of history
a better sense of
of our stories and how we participated
them is definitely
definitely a way to to go
i love it man i love it my last question
for you today
we sign off all our podcasts with before
i ask you to sign off and tell
our audience within connect with you my
last question for you today
what makes a life worth living
this is gonna it's not gonna sound
inspirational but i think i think that a
life
a life worth living sorry but what makes
a life worth living is a
is understanding the proper
hierarchy of values which lead
up to the highest it's like
understanding where things are
and then seeing all goods at the level
that they are
and so one of the things that makes us
miserable is that we
we try to put too much good in things
that are relative goods
right and so eating having a nice meal
is a good thing
but but we someone who puts all their
their life in there is going to be
disappointed
and there's a hierarchy of that it's
like having it being in a relationship
with
with your spouse is a good thing but
even that is a relative good and then
ultimately moving towards
the higher and higher goods i think that
that's what that's what makes a life
worth living because it gives you like a
track and a path and you can actually
see your progress right it's like
oh when someone used to say that before
i get really pissed off and i'd like
lose it and now it's like oh i can oh i
can kind of hold myself
in and i can i can you know i can stay
calm and it's like oh wow that's awesome
and then you and then you just keep
going like that and you know
move towards something beyond yourself
you know
man i am i've been a huge fan for a
while um
i feel like i've learned so so much
today please
excuse my ignorance on a number of the
topics but i i really really do
appreciate you coming on i feel like you
were
a force of good a force of good so man
thank you so much for coming on the show
yeah thanks i really enjoyed this and i
i appreciate your
your capacity to like really great
questions or
insightful questions in the sense that
i can tell that you thought about what
you were going to ask before you asked
it so i really appreciate that it makes
you a good conversation